[Musik]
hallo in ihm heute gibt es mal
ausnahmsweise kein rezept von mir
sondern ein 23 euch wie ihr diese schön
xxl überraschungseier aus styropor
selber machen könnt das überraschungsei
ist in holen so dass ihr das befüllen
könnt entweder mit schokolade oder auch
mit ganz anderen dingen die styropor
eier die ich hier verwende die habe ich
auf einem bastelbedarf online shop und
zwar ist es der vbs hobby verband ich
schreibe euch aber die genaue adresse
nach unten in die infobox die kommt mit
zwei halbkugeln daher ist 30 zentimeter
groß und die könnte dann einfach so
zusammensetzen
im zusammengesetzten zustand mal ich
jetzt zuallererst mit einem bleistift
dieses gipfel also den unteren roten
rand
anschließend muss noch diesen typischen
preis und tropfen aus damit ich den
hinterher aus sparen kann
[Musik]
mit
an der stelle werde ich das ganze rot
anmalen und war mit acrylfarbe damit
kann man einfach am besten mal auf
styropor
ich habe hier rot verwendet weil das
typische das überraschungsei ihr könnt
aber auch themenbezogen jeder andere
farbe benutzen die farbe habe ich mir
dann hier in so eine kleine schüssel
gegeben und zuallererst werde ich mit
einem dünnen pinsel den rand zeichnen
und an der stelle habe ich auch die
halbkugeln auseinander genommen so habt
ihr einfach viel mehr stabilität auf der
arbeitsfläche
[Musik]
wenn ihr zuerst die ränder ausmacht mit
eurem dünnen pinsel dann habt ihr
einfach viel mehr kontrolle und ihr malt
auch nicht aus versehen drüber
[Musik]
damit es dann auch wirklich schneller
geht und ihr nicht mit dem dünnen pinsel
alles ausmalt könnt ihr den rest mit
einem dicken pinsel auffüllen
[Musik]
das ganze muss dann jetzt einmal
trocknen mit der acrylfarbe geht das
auch ziemlich schnell also innerhalb von
einer halben stunde sollte das ganze
auch trocken sein
[Musik]
als nächstes habe ich mir aus dem
internet die vorlage ausgedruckt und
ausgeschnitten
hier habe ich allerdings nur den
schriftzug der überraschung genommen und
später auch oben plus - cacau das habe
ich mir auch noch ausgedruckt und das
kinder werde ich aber durch den namen
ersetzen
die schriftart helvetica baby kommt der
schrift von dem kinder am nächsten und
so habe ich mir dann die buchstaben für
den namen ausgedruckt
[Musik]
die einzelnen elemente werden jetzt noch
auf das überraschungsei geklebt und hier
nimmt ihr am besten einen starken kleber
damit er auch nichts passieren kann
[Musik]
über den überraschungs trifft so kommt
jetzt der name und hier habe ich auch
den ersten buchstaben in schwarz
ausgedrückt und den rest in rot
[Musik]
nachdem ihr dann alles aufgeklebt hat
ist das überall so weit auch schon
fertig und es muss nur noch gefüllt
werden
passend zu den sommerferien möchte ich
euch aber noch einen weiteren zweck
zeigen und verwirrt die liebe lina
eingeschult und dafür habe ich mir ihren
schriftzug aufgedruckt und ein paar
schulkinder
[Musik]
und das ist doch mal eine schöne
ergänzung zur standard schultüte hier
noch eine weitere idee für alle die das
opferfest feiern die schreibe euch den
linken so auch in die infobox da könnt
ihr euch die ganz einfach ausdrucken
jetzt muss das ein nur noch gefüllt
werden ich nehme mir natürlich am
liebsten wachen der marke ferrero und
vor allem schokolade der kinder
[Musik]
und fertig ist das 30 zentimeter xxl
styropor
wie ihr seht kann man das ganz einfach
öffnen und schließen und das doch mal
eine überraschung also wenn sich da
keiner freut dann weiß ich auch nicht
weiter
verpackt habe ich das mit durchsichtiger
geschenk folie und einem hübschen roten
band
[Musik]
falls ihr jetzt noch eine live action
der beschenkten sehen möchtet dann
bleibt auf jeden fall dran
[Musik]
falls euch das tutorial gefallen hat
dann würde ich mich sehr über einen
daumen nach oben freuen und über ein abo
bin ich nicht mehr verpassen möchte bis
zum nächsten mal auf s kitchen